[Music]
disappointing comes down to one game
after a long season then just
disappointing Ptolemy's I guess to try
to learn what you can but it's tough we
just didn't execute coach had a good
strategy we just didn't execute trying
to throw the ball downfield and McKay he
had a great game I didn't support him I
feel bad
do you have any comment on your
impending free agency well yeah that's
too early to it's too early to get into
that I mean I got that I gotta meet with
my family and we got to take some time
and make a decision together but for now
I mean this is my team these these are
my guys I know what's a dick and what's
a microphone at this point